[Music]
hello welcome to dear Hank and John nor
does that first think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast for me
and my brother John that's the other guy
there we talk to each other we give
you'd abuse advice we answer your
questions and we bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon how do you do it John I'm
doing well as you know Hank I'm in the
midst of this 100 day health and fitness
challenge we're over at youtube.com
slash 100 days my best friend Chris and
I are trying to have a healthy midlife
crisis and I'm a little sore right now
to be perfectly honest you know John my
whole body hurts
so in addition to the soreness I have I
have in my life attempted to get in
shape before and I'm not tremendously
out of shape I do like I do like to
structured workouts a week I've done
that for years and and it's kept it's
like been really good maintenance for me
but in the times when I've tried to like
like be much more active about it you
know what I notice mmm is that it takes
a ton of time it's not just like the
physical effort it's just like oh how
does anybody have an extra hour a day
well so I have an interesting answer for
that question in general I find that
when you make things a priority they
happen and that literally nothing should
be a higher priority than then your
health except maybe your family and even
that's arguable so there's that the
second thing though is that I have found
it's the mental health benefits of
exercise to be so dramatic in the last
you know a couple months that I've been
doing this that I save time because time
that would otherwise go to my obsessive
thinking patterns and the compulsions
that I used to deal with them instead
that time goes to exercise and then I
find that I have like more time each day
for actual like work and hanging out
with my family and stuff so I for me
there's an upside to it but it's like
with anything it's just what it's what
you make a priority and and and what
you don't and I think there's a good
argument to be made that you know you
don't need to make exercising to the
point of exhaustion for an hour a day a
priority yeah yeah and and that is sort
of what I realized like I will never
have that you know that ideal body shape
I will have a less than ideal but still
healthy body shape and that that is my I
mean I'm not doing this for body shapes
right I'm past the point in my life
where I'm obsessed with live shapes the
point in your life would you could have
an ideal body shape this is not possible
for a for a man your age that's a great
point I'm never gonna have a six-pack my
that my six-pack ship has sailed
Hank would you like a short poem for
today yeah ships no it's about it's
about love and loss it's one of my very
favorite short poems I can't believe
I've never read it in fact I might have
but if I have then you're hearing it for
a second time and it's still great it's
by Tom Gunn it's called James Ian it's
it's just a tiny little couplet their
relationship consisted in discussing if
it existed I think we all know that
feeling of having been in a relationship
that consisted primarily of discussing
whether it existed I'm very grateful to
be out of that game I'll tell you that
yeah yeah yeah it exists well I mean
that's the nice thing about marriage
it's legally binding yeah the state has
agreed that it exists exactly a
government has acknowledged that your
relationship is real hey let's answer
some questions from our listeners ok
sure this one is from Maggie I found
this question very weird and and
surprisingly deep dear Hank and John I
made a fart joke and my mom said I can't
do that
and then responded by saying that Hank
green makes fart jokes she agreed with
me that if I can get on the podcast she
will let me make fart jokes please help
also I was on a train derailment and
almost died and help us appreciate it
ignore the train derailment part of the
fart ship because the fart jokes are
more important I use humor as a defense
mechanism Maggie oh sorry here about
this is I mean I love that question so
much Maggie I really appreciate the way
that you're handling what I imagine is a
traumatic time in your life I mean that
question had a plot twist that I have
not seen the likes of since the usual
suspects I mean I was going in one
direction and now I'm going in a whole
different direction because suddenly
like Maggie's making a fart joke in the
middle of this nearly fatal train
derailment first off Maggie I'm glad
you're I'm glad you're okay yeah I don't
know that she was making a fart joke
during the train derailment but I do
think that Maggie's mom should
understand well first of all we've
already solved the problem
she can make fart jokes now it's great
we you're on the pot it happened but I'm
so tense made fart jokes since I was a
little kid and I've never thought that
they were that funny but well I always
brought him great pleasure I think in
general it's important if you're making
a fart joke that it be funny sometimes
sometimes it's just like fart and you're
like ha that's wasn't you've heard my
best fart joke ever story John right
uh-huh no but I'm sure you're gonna tell
it all right so I was in this very long
long and boring business meeting it was
like this sort of like for VidCon I
think it was VidCon 2013 or 14 all
everybody was together in this room and
we had this day-long meeting because the
team was pretty remote so he brought
everybody together and it's just it's
just a lot of details that needed to get
ironed out we were in like hour seven of
this meeting and Carver who you remember
yeah was going through some something
and I noticed that every time Carver
gets an email a thing pops up and it
says the emails from and it says this
subject of the email and his his uh his
email his computer is being broadcasted
to the entire room of people and so we
all see like the emails Carver's getting
and the subject of each email so I sit
back in my chair and I said Carver an
email and wait and I just and I'm so
happy I'm just like suddenly I've
reached this moment of perfect bliss and
and then a
the screen arrives the email to Carver
from Hank green subject line fart fart
fart and like and there's like a giggle
and then there's like another in
Carver's just talking about like signage
or whatever and then there's another
olympos like laughter and then everybody
is like the tension is broken and
finally we're all okay and I was just
like I am a magic man fart fart fart I
mean I would say that that's the kind of
story where you had to be there for it
to be funny except that I strongly
suspect if I had been there I also would
not have found that particularly funny
anyway I think Maggie's mom should
understand that maggie has to deal with
some stuff and and and jokes even if
they are slightly inappropriate a great
way to do that I have to say I'm a
little bit on Maggie's mom's side on
this one just because I have my own
children who are constantly making fart
jokes Hank your child is not big enough
yet but the it's the relentlessness of
them it it's the refusal to reach for
higher subject matter that I find so
exhausting like my kids genuinely think
the following is not just a joke but
like a joke on par with any joke that's
ever been told in the history of the
world doodoo head and I'll be like what
and Alice will say Henry said doodoo
head and that's why we've been laughing
for seven minutes yeah let people love
the things they love John do you want to
ask a question for us yeah I I'm trying
to get my children to get into some
sophisticated humor you know like Ogden
Nash poetry but it doesn't happen yet
it's just getting Ogden Nash made a ton
of fart jokes fart jokes result as
literature really this question comes
from Grace who writes Dear John and Hank
I recently gave my boyfriend poetry I
had written about him as part of his
Christmas present he received this
really well and it actually seems to
have brought us closer however watching
him read it and thinking about someone I
know reading my work is mortifying like
as I sit here thinking about him reading
my work I want to shove my face in a
pillow I like writing and part of me
wants to share it more
but I also feel so vulnerable sharing it
how do I get past this suffocating an
embarrassment grace
Hank I wanted to ask you this question
because I do not know the answer and I'm
hoping that you can help me not feel
embarrassed and mortified by the
prospect of sharing work that I have
made with strangers
or with indeed with with with boyfriends
etc I thought that this was this was
purely practice like the more you did it
the better it got is that is that not
the case no not in my experience like
I've had Sara read something relatively
recently and it's just awful
like it's so nerve-racking
and weird and uncomfortable and you feel
so exposed and I think part of it well I
yeah I I have I have a thing that I have
just sent to to Catherine and to and to
a friend who is a professional writer
but not me but not no no that's an
interesting thing like I do not want you
to read the thing that I've written and
to it is published
I like there's be very nervous I don't
know why you make me more nervous than
than Catherine or this friend of mine
who I'm not mentioning intentionally and
Minerva s' to hear what they have to say
I I mostly just want it to be over with
when I want them to finish and tell me
but but but when I read the things that
I write like I know when they are
terrible I'm I feel like I'm I'm at the
point now where I I'm conscious of like
what the problems are mm-hmm and I think
that's a that's a big important part of
any of not being nervous about anything
like of course I still get nervous like
when there's when there is an element of
the of the like uncontrollable I could
going up on stage you never know what's
gonna happen you never know what you're
gonna mess up you never know what the
audience is gonna do but but but in
times when when there are
a lot of variables that I can control
for I find myself like I seek out those
variables I control for them and then I
move forward but there is a lot of there
is a lot of subjectivity in
interpretation of any of any art form
and so you like people are some people
are gonna receive it well and some
people are gonna receive it negatively
that's just gonna happen but but I find
like if I can read something that I
wrote and say that's good and I and like
it's somebody who thinks that that's not
good is wrong okay can you do that I do
not have that ability no no no no no and
I also don't think I'm a particularly
good judge of what is working like a lot
of times I think you know something and
something that I'm writing I well maybe
I recognize that it doesn't work but I
still think it's really good and it's
only when i zoom out or take some time
or listen to people I trust that I
realize like oh like The Fault in Our
Stars should not end with hazel
literally tied to railroad tracks
because that that's like that's you know
that's just bananas like it makes no
sense
but I I don't a lot of times recognize
that in the moment and so I think that's
part of what I find stressful about
sharing my work with people but I also
think the one thing I guess I'd say to
grace is that you've got to remember
that you know your boyfriend cares about
you and he's going to read your work
generously and there's an element of
that that I think it just makes a huge
difference you know like when you feel
like you're gonna be read generously
it's a lot less scary than when you feel
like you're going to be read from a
place of judgement now like it's
important to read stuff critically and
to read from a place of judgment I think
I so I'm not I'm not saying that you
know I I don't welcome those readings
but III do think in general like the
most fulfilling reading experiences I
have start with me saying I am excited
to read this book and find find what I
like in it or I am excited to hear this
poem from grace and find what I like in
it rather than like I am reading this to
confirm what I already suspect which is
that there is something about it
right there's also there's also an
element of like like I have a much less
hard time watching somebody watch one of
my videos if it's pure comedy you know
then if it's like me being open about
myself and about the world and like
baring my soul a little bit like I don't
want to be in the room when people are
watching that video especially if it's
about the person that I made it for
right like like in that in that
particular circumstance where it's like
I made this for you and it is an opening
of my soul and like and like an attempt
of like to say things that I don't know
how to say then he's like yes you want
to run away and not be in the room and
be like here I'm gonna go let me know
what you think I'll be the cafeteria I
don't know I was gonna be in the
cafeteria yeah maybe that's the best way
to way to do it grace is just to
disappear for a while and then let your
boyfriend on his own time respond to
your poetry but I don't know we're a
couple of middle-aged people who haven't
found our way through this obviously
Hank like we're not really giving grace
advice right now we're giving each other
advice and I think often the case but
not not in the case of this question
John which is a harder one and and and a
real real interesting one to me dear
Hank and John I have been online
catfishing a girl for about four years
now at Oh God and think to be someone
else so god the picture that is not me
oh god I know that that makes me sound
like an absolute psychopath however it's
104 szimpla tonic and I feel so so bad
about it I had a fake a cat when I was
younger just to mess with people in my
hometown and I found this awesome girl
she's bold and strange and she
understands me on a level that no one
else does I can't keep living a lie but
I also can't tell the truth it would
hurt her even more than me what should I
do just ignore her forever maybe I'm in
way way too deep any dubious advice
would it be helpful you are the only
people I've ever talked to about this
catfish and penguins anonymous oh god
I'm covered I mean if I couldn't find my
way to the last question Hank I
certainly can't find my way through this
question I mean I I mean that sounds
like
very intense and unpleasant experience
but also kind of one that you have
you've put on yourself I understand like
it's it's like the lobster that that
does not notice that the water is
getting warm until suddenly it is
boiling I guess but boy
yeah you know Hank just a quick side
story that I've told before when I met
my first real girlfriend who I met on
the Internet in the in the old old days
of the Internet I drove all the way
across the country to meet her after you
know like talking back and forth to each
other for two years and I'd never seen a
picture of her because back then like it
was uncommon to send pictures over the
internet because it would like cost a
ton of money and and like whenever I
talked about the relationship that we
had which ended up being like a great
relationship that lasted for several
years people always say like oh and she
was nothing like how she described
herself and I always say like no like we
didn't really describe ourselves like we
never really talked about each other
physically like that wasn't like the
internet was so different than all of
which is to say that I feel even less
qualified to answer this question having
been in a situation where catfishing
could have easily occurred but didn't
yeah I mean I think I'm gonna call you
Igor because because we need a name
Igor you've all you've already you know
what would be better though what Ryan oh
right right right of course Ryan you
you've already in effect done the
hurting it's just that it's just that
the nervous system hasn't picked up the
pain yet that already happened you have
hurt this person and and and and maybe
there are ways to hurt to make the hurt
hurt less but the the offense has
already occurred and I know that it
wasn't necessarily something that you
meant to be meant to do from the
beginning and and you've got yourself
weighing over your head one one little
step at a time but
and you didn't know that you were bullet
boiling your Lobster in that pot but
Ryan you you got it you got to end this
and you got a and and it may be just
going to cold turkey or it may be
telling the person the truth and and
moving on but like you you are every
this every time you continue the
relationship you are making the hurt
worse in the eventual moment when the
hurt happens right the other thing I
would say from Ryan is I get a vibe from
the email that maybe Ryan thinks that
like maybe there's a world in which this
friendship can continue after this is
revealed and I'm not here to say that's
not possible but I I do strongly think
that in the likelihood that this person
does not want to continue a relationship
you need to honor that 100% you need to
just you need to honor that because you
have to understand that they will likely
be hurt in a way that they can't you
know that there's no real coming back
from maybe not but I think you have to
honor that if that's what they want all
right I think we have another question
this one comes from Ian who writes Dear
John and Hank I was drinking a lovely
dark red wine blend with my sister last
night and I didn't rinse the glass until
after the tiny wine puddle at the bottom
of the glass had dried completely side
note Ian I do not believe in leaving
that tiny wine puddle I will stick my
finger into the bottom of the glass just
to get that get all the wine out of
there and I'll lick my finger to make
sure that I get all of the wine anyway I
just I love wine Hank also I'm I have a
very restricted amount of wine that I'm
about to drink during this 100 days so
that might be somewhat related anyway
when I ran water into the glass it
turned not as I expected a diluted red
but instead a muted but very dis
Inked blue when i rinsed a glass with a
still wet puddle of wine the water
turned the normal red color I assume
there's some chemical explanation for
this but I'm no expert John likes wine
and Hank likes chemistry so clearly you
are experts enlighten the world
shellfish and eyesores Ian Oh Hank I
don't like shellfish and I source no
those are like two of my least favorite
things actually Hank I do not know why
this happened also it has never happened
to me and I have drunk a fair few
glasses of wine in my day well you're
never leaving the crust at the bottom
side oh not certainly not lately
good lord I mean it's a very strict
eight ounces at most per day so so yeah
I am I am like 90% of the way to to
being sure I know why this happens so so
the stuff that makes red wine bread is a
chemical the bunch of different chemical
they're chemicals called anthocyanins
and anthocyanins change color depending
on the pH of the of the solution that
they are in so when you took when you
took the anthocyanins out of solution
completely my guess is that the acids
whatever they are which I don't know
we're also able to escape somehow and
then you diluted the diluted that with
probably what is slightly basic tap
water in some places tap water is
slightly basic because of the chemicals
in the ground so probably you have
what's called hard water and in here
you're the water in your house is
slightly basic now I actually this
morning because I wanted to be sure of
this I took some red wine which I had a
little bit of left from when my friend
was visiting and I put it into a glass
and and then I put some dish some like
laundry detergent which is super basic
into the glass and then diluted that the
color I got was not blue but it like it
was a very distinct color change from
from bright red to a gray like a sort of
a blackish gray I have to stop you right
there Hank yeah
are you telling me that you took
drinkable useable red wine you poured it
into a glass and you then put laundry
detergent in the glass with the
drinkable red wine rather than drinking
the red wine I mean I gotta tell you
John not only did I do that I used
several other chemicals to see what the
best one was and laundry detergent was
was the best one I used bleach which is
not not a basic and very that's a very
negative effect on the taste I've heard
that that turned a very bright yellow
which was interesting and I also used
some calcium carbonate which made like
sort of a murky chalky gray or white
which was also really interesting I
think that probably some of the calcium
carbonate came out a solution and
precipitated into made it made it murky
and cloudy but but I don't know super a
ton about what chemistry is happening
here but I do know that there are lots
of pigments that change colors based on
the pH anthocyanins and wine are one of
them and yeah so you you are seeing the
the the change in the and the pigment
that actually makes red wine red I'm
interested in why yours turned out blue
mine turned out black and I don't know
if that's different anthocyanins and
different brands of wine but I would be
interested in that I think like I get
kind of in my mind's eye be like I can
see a little blue in that black but but
I wouldn't say that I feel like probably
I was just being biased by the question
but yeah wine the the the pigmented wine
is a pH indicator and wine is acidic and
it is so what red one will be red for as
long as it is is it acidic and then when
it is basic it will be a different color
and it will taste absolutely horrible
possibly deadly don't do that don't
drink wine that has bleach in it I don't
know that I needed to say that just
drink the wine and you don't ask
questions
that's lesser I don't have some antacids
and put it in the wine to see if that
would get a more distinct color change
but I wasn't it was not able to make
that work I mean this this is deeply
offensive to me we need to move on this
question comes from tosit who writes
dear green brothers well that's a
strategy for getting around the Dear
John and Hank
I would love a nerdfighter shirt but I
don't really have money to spend on
things like that is it okay if I make my
own like with fabric paint on a blank
shirt I don't want to select your
company or commit some kind of copyright
infringement I wouldn't be selling them
or anything I just want to make one or
two shirts for myself Thanks do it
also I wish yeah please do it no Hank
and I I remember in the in the early
early days of Brotherhood 2.0 Hank and I
used to say that we didn't want to make
sure it's because we wanted all
nerdfighter shirts to be homemade
because they were always so much better
than whatever shirts you could buy on
the internet but then eventually we you
know we started dftba calm and an aside
from selling music i started selling
shirts but we still think like the best
nerdfighter shirts are homemade and a
lot of times like our favorite our
favorite shirts that are for sale at
dftba.com are shirts that we discovered
online somewhere or that somebody was
wearing in line that they'd made
themselves and the shirt was just so
great we were like where did you get
that and they're like we made it and
they're then we'll be like great can we
sell it at the FDA so yeah keep making
shirts don't worry about it there's a
reason we haven't copyright or trademark
the word nerdfighter or the phrase dftba
and it's so that you can feel free to
make that stuff without worrying or even
thinking about it like we we are
grateful to you for caring enough about
this community to want to brag about it
on a t-shirt so thank you and don't
worry about it at all don't worry about
it at all III remember one time I did a
I did like a live TV like a blog TV live
show yeah and then the next day I did a
like an actual in-person live show and
there were people with shirts like
referencing a joke that reference but
referencing a joke that was made in that
vlog TV live show yeah that's just the
gas phase there's no way to do that
faster that is the only way you can do
that I remember in Paper Towns there at
one point Margo wears a t-shirt that's
like a pink t-shirt featuring an orange
dragon breathing green fire or something
I don't remember and when I went on tour
for Paper Towns like I'd been on book
were a lot of times before and it's
pretty soul-crushing to go from like
city to city and talk to like six people
or twelve people or a large group of
high school students who don't know who
you are and don't want to be there but
this is their way to get out of English
class or whatever like manure ring
really difficult and and like you know
obviously it's a great opportunity to
talk about your book and everything but
at the same time it's it's just kind of
emotionally exhausting and I remember
the first tour stop for Paper Towns
there were people wearing like homemade
pink t-shirts with the green dragon
breathing orange fire or whatever and I
was just like oh oh oh my god oh my god
this is gonna be so fun
this is gonna be the exact opposite of
all my previous tours and it really was
like that was the first time when I
thought like oh god this is I mean yeah
it just that was that was the moment
when I realized that nerdfighteria had
changed my creative life in this like
deep and lasting way so yeah please
we're all for homemade t-shirts they're
the best all right since we're on the
topic of criteria we got a question from
Georgia who asks dear Hank and John for
Christmas I found out that my dad and my
sister and I will be flying from Canada
to Boston for nerdcon nerdfighteria
which is a February 24th 25th I'm pretty
sure is that Rachel I don't know but you
can find out more and get tickets at
nerdcon nerdfighteria com or just go to
nerdcon comm and McCann find a link
there as well and it's it's February
25th and 26th but I got real close
February 25th and 26th and it and it's
it's 60 bucks for for two days of high
quality and joy extraordinarily excited
and can't wait says Georgia and also
Hank this will be my first con of any
variety and my first time meeting any
nerdfighters outside of my family and
those I've brought into this myself I've
been watching videos for a couple of
years but I'm worried that I'm not
enough of a nerdfighter I'm not sure why
maybe because I'm still relatively new
to the community or because the first
project I actively participated was p4a
2016 maybe I just don't feel like enough
of a nerd or that I am NOT an that I'm
not unabashed enough about my interests
I don't want to arrive at nerdcon I
don't want to arrive
nerdcon and suddenly feel shy or feel
like I don't fit in because
nerdfighteria aligns with my morals and
opinions on the world but I also don't
want to embarrass myself by being not
nerdfighteria enough am i overthinking
this yes yes any dubious advice would be
appreciated as you are close to expert
as you are as close to experts on
nerdfighteria as they come also if you
have any comment it's that I can
guarantee that they will be put to good
use wear comfortable shoes Georgia
that's my Khan related tip bring a
balance bar to yeah bring some snacks
that's the other thing that I would say
I I think you are overthinking this and
I think the reason you're overthinking
it is because you're excited but also
nervous because it is a new thing and it
is not something that you have done
before and it is good and exciting and
fun to do new things but it is also
somewhat scary but uh when you are there
it will flow naturally and it will feel
like a natural fun thing to be doing and
you'll go from panel to panel or event
to event and you'll have a good time and
you'll talk to people about their
t-shirts hopefully homemade t-shirts but
also t-shirts available now at dftba.com
and it will be fun but I always feel
this way before I go to a conference and
then the vast majority of the time I'm
able to have a great time there have
been a couple of exceptions in my life
but almost all the time it's really
really great yeah it's like it's that
feeling that you are feeling right now
is such a familiar feeling to me one
that I've had many times pretty much
everybody even go to a concert I have
that where I'm like I need a my if I end
up with a fan to even go to a concert
should I wear the shirt of the band or
should I wear a shirt feels like a
peripheral band that's like over to the
side how do I look cool enough for this
should I sing along with the songs what
about if I don't know about Valen or the
court should I sing along then like way
over analyzing it and it's really like
and that can that can kind of be a
detriment because it can make you feel
like I don't want to take any risks but
I really like I think that that these
experiences can be more rewarding if you
do take a couple of risks here and there
and try things that you wouldn't
normally do and and I think that's one
of the great things about being able to
get out into the real world at
place where there people who have
similar values to you and get a chance
to engage and connect with those people
which I hope happens a lot yeah I do
that I totally agree and I think you
know getting over the in in a way just
getting over the hump of like buying the
tickets and making the plans is the
hardest part and then you're on the
other side of it and once you're there
it you know if the conference people
have done their job it should flow
pretty naturally and and be pretty
straightforward and easy for you and
since I am not directly involved in
nerdcon or VidCon these days I can tell
you that Hank and his team do an amazing
job of that I think I think they put
together really really wonderful
experiences for people and give lots of
opportunities for you to have a good
experience now obviously that doesn't
mean that everyone will but I write it
it's really great what they do there
they're a wonderful group of people they
and they have wonderful values and they
do a great job and we should also
mention while I'm talking about that
that in addition to tickets to nerdcon
nerdfighteria Hank and I will also both
be at VidCon Europe in Amsterdam in
April which I am very excited about I
wasn't gonna go and I wasn't gonna go
and I wasn't gonna go but then the war
of Amsterdam proved too much to me that
is April 7th to 9th if you want to hang
out in Amsterdam I know it's gonna be
tons of fun and tickets to VidCon in
Anaheim are also for sale as our tickets
to VidCon Australia which is this fall
and you won't be coming to Australia
right John no I mean unless I get the
bug at the last second but I really like
this thing where I thought well I don't
promise to do stuff and then I can do it
if I want to rather than feeling
obligated this is from harima who asks
dear Hank and John the first
vlogbrothers video I saw was the slobber
carrots punishment and I thought it was
really stupid however less than a month
after that I started to watch
vlogbrothers again and I liked it
it took me another few weeks to realize
that the two videos were from the same
Channel now I love the slobber carrots
video what happened why did I suddenly
love a video that I hated just a couple
of months before that's a great question
Oh what happened John
what happened to her I mean I think what
probably happened is my guess is that
the slobber carrots video is only a good
video if you care about the people who
made it specifically me and my kid and I
think after watching a bunch of our
other videos that hopefully are good
even if you don't care about us the
slobber carrots video became kind of
magically better and that's I'm one of
the weird things about vlogbrothers over
the years is that it's always been this
mix of content that really only makes
sense to slash can be enjoyed by
nerdfighteria and then videos that are
made for a sort of like broader world
outside of nerdfighteria and so maybe
that's what happened that's what I
that's what I'm guessing I think that's
a really good point
harima actually goes on in this question
to basically say how do I like it seems
wrong for me to feel that way shouldn't
I dislike shouldn't I keep disliking
something if I disliked it once and and
do I have this weird bias now and how do
I identify that bias to make sure that I
only like stuff if I actually like it
but that's the thing like the more you
know about something you're gonna like
different things like as like now I like
books that I never would have liked
before because I've read more books and
so like like certain books don't
satisfied me the way that they used to
because maybe they were simpler and had
more like more conventional expectations
but I didn't know that because I hadn't
read a lot and now that I've read more
I'm like yeah I'm not so interested in
that and I want something that will
define my expectations a little more and
that happens not just in media but in
all things in life as things get more
complicated you realize maybe you
appreciate something in a way that you
didn't before and that's that's part of
growing and being a different person
because you never yeah you've never the
same person from one day the next
doesn't seem like it but that's the way
it is Hank we've got a question from a
Linnea who writes Dear John and Hank
I've recently purchased a pretty cool
Steven universe t-shirt which is red
with a large yellow star in the middle I
love this shirt however I have a dilemma
every time I wear this shirt to a public
place someone makes a comment about how
much I must love Carl's jr.
for those of you who don't know Carl's
jr. is a restaurant chain here in the
United States run by apparently our next
Secretary of Labor so that's a thing
it's a hamburger restaurant it's sort of
a not great Wendy's is how I would
describe it a lesser Wendy's anyway
Lanier writes I do not enjoy Carl's jr.
my question is this how do I go about
wearing this piece of pop-culture merch
without accidentally endorsing a
restaurant chain that I strongly dislike
hot dogs and pork chops
Linnea first of all that logo is not the
Carl's jr. logo so so Steven universe
yet they got the yellow star on a red
shirt red shirt Carl's jr. yellow star
with a smiley face in it on a red
background and then you have Homestar
Runner which is a white star on a red
shirt it's very confusing there's too
much going on here
and weirdly enough I googled this and
there is if there's a reddit thread from
2014 Forbes on the Steven universe
subreddit it says everyone thought I was
promoting Carl's jr. yeah I mean I'm
looking at this t-shirt right now Hank
because the name was kind enough to send
a picture we'll send will post it on the
patreon at patreon.com slash dear Hank
and John and looking at this particular
t-shirt my number one conclusion from it
having never seen the TV program Steven
universe is that that is a Hardee's
and/or Carl's jr. t-shirt 100% no
question well that case Steven universe
is a big fan of Hardee's because that is
the shirt that Steven universe wears
well I'm just telling you if I saw
someone wearing that t-shirt in a public
place I don't think to myself Wow I mean
that is weird that someone would be that
into Hardee's and/or Carl's jr. because
they are weirdly there are two companies
Hardee's and Carl's jr. that have the
same basically the exact same menu and
are owned by the same people and have
very similar logos but are different
restaurant chains and so if I saw it
because I I am in a Hardee's part of
America I would almost definitely think
well I guess Linnea I mean I guess I
wouldn't know her
no I'd probably guess it from the
t-shirt though I guess Linnea is a huge
Hardy's fan which is which is probably
not your fault it is it is the creator
of Steven universe's fault probably for
not accurate yeah what I would say to
Linnea is you just need to add something
in puff paint to the bottom of the shirt
that makes it absolutely clear that you
don't love Hardy it's like I am opposed
to Hardy's would be one thing that you
could add you know you might be able to
get that puff paint by the way from
tossin who's going to be designing his
own fighter shirt that's gonna that's
gonna be a little confusing to the
average person like now it's just an
anti Hardy's shirt not a pro Steven
universe shirt well maybe like above the
star you can have I am strongly in favor
of the television program Steven
universe I mean listen Hank uh this is
off the cuff here so like you might you
might find ways to shorten this or
whatever but that's what I would write
in puff paint above the above the star
and then below the star I would be like
also for the record I do not like
Hardy's or Carl's jr. because I think if
you just say I do not like Carl's jr.
people are gonna think - you're a
Hardee's fan fangirl you know you know
what uh you know what who the truly
unsung hero of this moment is who people
who love Steven universe and Hardee's I
know those people are like on the
internet right now searching for this
very t-shirt they're like I found yet
I've found this shirt that represents my
values the Steven universe values and
the Hardys values well this podcast by
the way is brought to you by the Steven
universe Hardee's Carl's jr. Coalition
fandom Steven universe Hardee's Carl's
jr. Coalition fandom seven people in in
the in the middle of the country
somewhere including our next Labor
Secretary I think I can't remember which
member of the cabinet he's gonna be
today's podcast is also brought to you
by farting farting Hank's number one
source of jokes now and one of my top 10
sources of joy is also brought to you by
destroying wine destroying wine it's fun
and it makes your
brother uncomfortable makes me extremely
uncomfortable it's just I ha
and of course today's podcast is brought
to you by grace is poetry Grace's poetry
please don't read it in front of her oh
god we have some a bunch of Corrections
first of all I have to say it was not
the Postal Service that rut or wrote and
performed it created brothers on a hotel
bed
it was Death Cab for Cutie which just
happens to have the same lead singer as
the postal service we have another
correction from Clarissa who says that
Elsa is not a princess because her
parents are dead so she is a queen I
hope that didn't spoil anything for
anyone
and also Thomas would like to say that
it was not the International
Telecommunications Union that decides
when to add new leap second seconds but
the I ers the International earth
rotation and reference systems service
now I don't know what the relationship
between the ITU and the ie ers is Mike
my guess is that it's complicated and I
bet it's like Hatfield and McCoys like
they just absolutely hate each other and
they've been at war for so long they
can't even remember what they're
fighting about but they hate each other
and if you work at the AI ers I bet you
wake up every morning and you think what
can I do to take those itu mofos down
this is from Thomas Nelson who's from
the Swedish Institute of Space physics
so luckily not from neither of those
organizations so if he was from one of
them I would call him biased but since
he's from the Swedish Swedish Institute
of space physics which is not easy to
say I'm trusting him on this even though
the wicked you think it's hard to say in
English try saying it in Swedish I like
to imagine that the Swedish Institute of
space physics is kind of like the the
mediator in the horrible relationship I
er s and the ITU yeah yeah they're like
we're the Switzerland of this I know
it's confusing for Sweden but trust us
yeah well I mean they're basically the
same Thomas just kidding just kidding
please come to VidCon Europe Thomas of
course in his work at the Swedish
Institute of space physics
is like living my dream I I desperately
desperately wished that I had been good
at physics especially space physics like
that's the thing I most would have liked
to have a gift for so I'm a little
jealous of the correction I just
searched on Twitter from June 21st 2016
correction from Seamus says and the
current Pope is Pope Francis so
apparently we got that one wrong at some
point I think we corrected ourselves on
that in a previous podcast not to worry
so we're good on that
we we didn't nail the the current Pope
like seven months ago we corrected
ourselves and then Hank has just
recorrect at us so thank you Hank want
to make um all right John we're gonna do
one more question before we get to the
all-important news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon it's from Sam who asks dear
Hank and John I've been trying as we all
should be to make myself a better person
someone that I like more and to always
think what would Captain Picard do but
often I find myself frustrated with
changing parts of myself that I feel
impossible to control not just things
that we accept and learn to love about
ourselves earliest tolerate like
appearance and voice but actions that
seem instinctive and thoughtless when
there's no time to think things through
or win in a relaxed environment I'm
running almost on autopilot do you have
any advice for dealing with the
regretable choices that we make and that
don't resonate with our hopes and images
of ourselves but we continue to make
anyway without thinking I can't help but
feel that I might just be a bad person
warmly yours Sam well you got a good
sign off that's a good start warmly
yours
John I am I am a creature of habit I
like to establish habits and I believe
in habits and I think that in a lot of
ways the way that we communicate is
often as sam says here instinctual in a
way like not instinct xual but like you
it's it's like the like we have
pre-programmed a set of responses and we
just use them without thinking and yeah
you go with your default choice yeah
yeah and and sometimes we can set
ourselves up with bad defaults and that
doesn't mean that we're bad people but
it means that we have
you consciously set up new habits and
that can be hard work and one of the
habits that I like to try and establish
is to actually like take a moment to
think before I say a thing because I
could and it has become more important
as I've gotten people who like will will
take a lot out of what I say like
particularly people who work for me they
might think that like like some
off-the-cuff comment meant a lot more to
them than it did to me and so taking
that beat to be like what is this person
going to think about the thing that I'm
gonna say and then how am I gonna feel
about say what I'm gonna say before I
say it has become a constant habit for
me that I think has made my
relationships better I am no good at
making better choices than my default
choices in in the heat at the moment I
do think it probably is great to spawn
and take a second before you say
something I I found like yeah I am like
100% on board with Sam on this one and
feel like I've made absolutely no
progress on this in the last like 20
years of my life the only thing that I
will say is that I used to habitually
lie like in conversation just just to
make it convenient not not like out of
malice or anything but someone would say
like Oh have you ever been to Cincinnati
and I would say yes just because you
know you don't want to seem like you
haven't been to Cincinnati or you want
to let the person continue with their
story and I do try now not to do that as
much although I still I find myself
doing it all the time with movies or
something someone will say like did you
see this movie no be like oh yeah I
don't even know what why why why am i
why am i saying that and even when I'm
saying it I'm just like why why did you
say that like now you're in a tough
position like because you've got to have
an opinion on you gotta have an opinion
on Batman vs Superman of film you have
not seen and also have no intention of
ever seeing and so I am still I am still
working on this and I die I think that
it's hard and difficult and one of the
weird things about humans
yeah I'm just I think
I spent a lot of time as a younger
person believing that every word that I
said was going to be something but
through which someone would judge me
and so I get that up early where it was
like I like I need to be very careful
about making sure that everything I say
makes me makes everybody think the right
thing about me which led to a lot of not
speaking at all
but but set maybe set me up for for
being fairly good at saying things that
that are gonna have the highest
probability if not people not making
people feel bad well I do think that
it's a fairly good goal although there
are times I don't know it's complicated
let's move on to the news from AFC
Wimbledon the great thing about sports
Hank is that it is it is cut and dry you
win or you lose or in the case of soccer
you often tie so since we last spoke
hank AFC wimbledon has it's been an
interesting time they had their third
round FA Cup tie against Sutton United
which was on American cable television
is very exciting except the game itself
was and I used this word sparingly when
talking about AFC Wimbledon wretched it
was a nil nil draw but even that score
line I think a bit flatters how horrible
the game was to watch and there was then
an FA Cup replay in which Sutton United
won they won 3-1 largely because of a
controversial red card that resulted in
AFC Wimbledon playing with only 10
players for the vast majority of the
game AFC Wimbledon were up 1 nil into
the second half but their defense
eventually tired with only 10 players
and they lost the game which is a bummer
on the upside in Ligue 1 things continue
to go quite well or at least relatively
well Wimbledon beat Oxford United on
January 14th which is a very good result
and while they are no longer in the
playoff positions and I think maybe I
mean you know look last season AFC
Wimbledon were the arguably the smallest
team in Ligue 2 this year they are
almost certainly the smallest team in
Ligue 1 so to be
in 12th place is great currently
Wimbledon having played 26 games are in
12th place on 36 points they are about
mmm eight points out of the playoff
spots but more importantly from my
perspective they are 11 points clear of
the drop so a mid-table finish would be
extraordinary for Wimbledon this season
especially since almost everyone picked
them to be relegated well the and the
franchise currently playing in Milton
Keynes is like three points out of the
drop so that's something else yep
that would be amazing I know B that
would be great it would be great to be
able to say farewell to them and not
have to play twice a year but we shall
see there is a lot of season to go and
the franchise currently playing in
Milton Keynes is extremely well
capitalized so they should be able to
buy some players in the in the January
transfer window whatever that means well
John on the surface of Mars there is a
there is a minivan driving around
driving up the side of a mountain which
is which is exciting it's it's gotten to
a place it in Gale Crater where in his
it is now regularly coming across
somewhat startling and amazing things as
it sort of moves backward in geologic
history as it goes up this up the side
of this mountain it has just found a
rock and I know rocks are just rocks but
it is a very beautiful rock and you can
see pictures of it maybe we'll put one
on the patreon that looks for all the
world like what it looks like when some
mud almost like some silty clay is is
wet and then dries up you get those what
I think there might be called like
desiccation fractures or desiccation
cracks and and like that makes these
like really sort of pretty geometric
shapes I probably seen this in various
places what happened with this rock is
that that happened sometime in the
distant geologic history of Mars when
some mud some wet mud wet with water
dried out created those cracks and then
some sediments Mike's gotten blown into
those cracks and
the whole thing petrified over a long
long period of time and then way after
that happened it this rock actually
fractured in a couple of places and
water seeped through it because it had
been covered by a bunch of dirt and so
grabbed water seeped through it left
deposits in those fractures and so we
can see not only like the original
formation that happened in water but
then the deposits that were left in the
rock and a much later date
also by liquid water flowing through the
subsurface of Mars and this this rock is
contains a great deal of geologic
history of Mars all of which is wet
that's very cool it's pretty rock and
they are now able to drive right up to
it take up some pictures and take some
samples from it and it has a good name
that I forgotten I didn't know I died I
didn't I didn't I didn't hold on just a
second what are they calling it it's a
fun name I'm gonna wait for it Hank
because I know it's gonna be that good
it's gonna be so fun it's gonna be like
it's like they're gonna call it the
doodoo head rock that's what Alice would
have named it oh it's called old Soaker
The Rock's Soaker that is setting an
extremely low bar for fun yeah oh man I
know it's a fun name I can't remember
what it is John but it's super fun old
Soaker Oh doodoo head all right what are
we learned today
well I mean nothing really for being
honest
we learned that Hank is willing to
completely ruin a perfectly acceptable
glass of red wine by pouring basis into
it
we learned that Carl's jr. and Hardee's
and Steven universe are all in fact the
same thing I think Steven universe fans
might have a word about that also
Hardee's fans we learned that fart jokes
are a pretty good defense mechanism if
you've just been not killed in a train
derailment we learned
shellfish and eyesores is a terrible
sign off for an email warmly yours much
better and nobody nobody nobody likes
that no oh
some people like shellfish and I guess
some people probably like I source you
know there's people out there who think
our current aesthetics are all wrong
so maybe it's not for you Hank but it
could be for someone I I do agree though
warmly yours is pretty great Hank it has
been a pleasure to podcast with you it's
been a pleasure to podcast with you too
can I just read you one question John I
don't think it requires any comment but
I think it's important I think an
important thing to say for us here at
dear Hank and John Clara asks dear Hank
and John I'm a college freshman and just
beginning to figure myself out although
there are certain things I'm very sure
about myself so just make core values
I'm very unsure of other things when I'm
asked by other people about my opinions
they're shocked when I tell them that I
don't know or am unsure of what I think
it took me a long time to become okay
with my own unsure uncertainty and it
strikes me as very odd that humans are
not okay with this why do we fear
uncertainty how are we supposed to
figure things out if we can't admit
being unsure how does all of this work
at least I'm certain of my name Clara
amazing sign off ulcerate sign off just
nothing needs to be said about that
question except that we here at dear
Hank and John are far too often so a
full of fun full of faux certainty and
and we should we should say that out
loud here with the place where we give
dubious advice so thanks Clara for the
great message
I completely agree I believe that I
don't know are the three most underrated
words in the English language and
frankly Hank you and I should both use
them more often
yes dear Hank and John is produced by
rosianna halse rojas and Sheridan Gibson
our editor is Nicholas Jenkins Victoria
Bonjour no his head our head of
community and communications our music
is by the great gunnarolla thank you so
much for listening you can email us at
Hank and John at gmail.com that's where
we get your questions or use the hashtag
dear Hank and John on Twitter where I am
John Green Hank is Hank green and as we
say in my hometown
don't forget the awesome
[Music]